Stay in the world to see Proposal town how morning
tank retro yes
cameron one to ten deer 3
what are you giving so braid strength
ah winter
tem end lite
koi tint rtu look and 4th
corresponding
[clap]
ah then cheer howu rice fetus rice
bread  Jun Haha
[Applause]
Ah ah
[Applause] Ah uh [Applause]
Ah, the cure rate
Ah, I won the National Film Award a while ago, and now,
ah, today's work is over.
Ah ah thank you so much You know there was a saying that I always carved in my heart when I was young, whoever
said that to the most personal thing is the most handicapped when I was studying movies
.  Written in a cheap ring Maybe warmed up my daughter's various places
Bench words Watch Stern What spice what is summer school What's going on
That means uh app Quarters Plum I'm going to eat 2
Martin's Girls I can do it
[Applause]
First of all, I'm at school at the end
I'm the kind of person who studied while watching Marty's movie, but it's
such an honor to be nominated together, but I didn't know at all about winning an award
.
When the American audience or people didn't know, there is a
teen hyung on my side who would always pick up a list and like my movies, and I really
love him.
Up is 5
[Applause]
And our Todd and Seminar who were nominated together
are all great directors
that I respect so much.  a fr de it development
initiative  Poeta eoseongcho okay 5n sha 5 share reason
[clap]
Thank you for knowing it swing county ext2 not
ah
[clap]